good evening members
officers and member of the public
and welcome to this seat this meeting of
the executive i will now read out the
emergency evacuation announcement
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building by the entrance doors to the
hall
continue straight on and exit
the building via the double doors on the
right to the car park which is the
assembly point please do not delay your
evacuation by collecting any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given
given permission to do so by council
staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded and please switch off
mobiles and turn or turn them to silence
members there is a need to use
microphones during the meeting when i
invite you to speak please wait until
there is a microphone in front of you
before speaking as microphones are
needed for hearing loop and for the
audio recording
please where possible assist in passing
microphones to each other and use the
hand gel and antibacterial wipes on the
tables if you do touch the microphones
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the constitution
i will ask for a show of hands
for and then against recommendations and
will also ask for the show of hands for
those wishing to abstain from voting
okay members we move to item one
apologies for absence
and we have received those from
councillor whatton our leader
i think everybody else is present sonia
item two
substitute members there are no
substitutes
item three non-members attending
we haven't any
item four minutes of the meeting held on
the 9th of september 2021 are these
minutes of grade members
thank you
item 5 to receive declarations of
interest
are there any declarations
you members
item six mata's referred to the
executive and reports from other
committees
uh the portfolio holder for environment
and place council dave sperm will
present this report thank you councillor
sperm
thank you chairman
the the parks for nature initiative uh
was brought in
for to review committee
for consideration
i think
i was quite surprised at the response
that
was present in that review meeting
officers and myself had gone round to
all the recreational areas and open
spaces
to
advise ward councillors of the
intentions what we wanted to do
and by and large i would say while we
were out and about the result the
reaction was very positive
at the meeting itself and i think
it's as it says in the report here 1.2
broadly endorsed the principle of parts
for nature
but there did seem to be
an underlying
feeling
that while a lot of people agreed with
the principle of parts for nature
they
also wanted to make sure that it didn't
affect their particular recreation area
or
they were very concerned and
despite the the fact that myself
councillor wootton mr hotton at all
agreed that we would reconsider or amend
any of our plans there seemed to be
um which i say
some concerns as to the way this was
going it may just have been my my
personal view
um
one
uh
councillor
raised the concern that in the public
consultation there were for only 400
replies
when asked
what number he thought would be
appropriate there was a deathly silence
there are those approximately 400
replies 92 percent agreed with the
policy of parks for nature
um
as i understand it
at the moment on the local plan we've
received and i might be
told that this is an incorrect figure
but i'm led to believe we've had
something in the region of 800.
responses
so i would suggest that 400
for parks for nature
is a pretty good response
um
so
i've i've seen the recommendation here
that
another working group is is set up
personally i
cannot endorse this recommendation
i believe that we have a better
phraseology and i believe it's necessary
that the parks for nature uh our open
spaces
working group be
uh very adjacent or involved with the
carbon neutrality and we've got a an
additional
recommendation here
if you wish to follow my my lead
chairman
oh sorry an alternative sorry not an
additional alternative
i don't know if uh mr horton's got
anything he wants to add
no
thank you chairman thank you councillors
baron
any questions
casa williams
i'll just come there council sparrow
just come in okay
okay members there is one recommendation
set out paragraph 2.1
let a member working party be
established to work jointly with
officers the portfolio holder for
environment and place and key
stakeholders along the carbon neutral
work
working part parking working party group
on proposals for each site
can those members in favor please raise
their hands
thank you members and can those members
against please raise their hands
okay
that's unanimous
so the
recommendation is lost
and councillor sparring would you like
to then present your
recommendation please
thank you chairman
the recommendation is the terms of
reference for the carbon neutral working
group is extended to include and
consider the needs of the open space
users
balanced against the council's objective
to improve its carbon footprint
thank you council spain councillor
williams
thank you
so members
can we have a vote please on the
new recommendation
those in favor
okay that's carried thank you
okay members we move on to item seven
the connect program
this report sets out the business cases
for those invest to save projects as
highlighted in the connect program
pipeline presented to the executive on
the 9th of september 2021
this is the work of the key change
champions
amy galter the council's ict business
support and relationship manager and
sonia worthington principal democratic
and corporate services officer are here
is here this evening
as the two key key change champion lead
officers for those projects
and dawn tribe assistant director
transformation and customer
is here as a senior responsible officer
for the connect program
the two projects are sharepoint and
onedrive migration
and committee management information
system upgrade
council fd would you like to present the
report please
thank you
um first i would like to thank dawn and
amy in this uh difficult times an
investor safe project
is always great and this will help us
save money over the long term
the um
sharepoint
is already being used by members and i'm
sure the officers will
have great use of it like we have as
members
and the savings on it are really great
over
a longer period of time and it should
take us no longer than three years 36
months to get our capital back and then
move on to some savings
and the
also
with the
cms
which also will
give us savings after about 18 months
and it will also help greatly with our
carbon neutrality
we're hopefully getting rid of a load of
paperwork
so i won't go into too much technical
detail because that's why amy and amy's
here and dawn's he was well deceiving so
i'm going with it thank you
so members i'm not going to repeat
anything um that's already contained in
the report and in the business plan but
i thought in terms of the seamless
upgrade
case it might be useful to show you
some screen shots
so
i can't slide
there we go um so i logged into another
council's my cms app using a tablet
and as i hope you can see on this
screenshot
was able to write freestyle on a
committee document and highlight
different sections of the report
my cms can be used on android or ios
tablets and on windows or mac laptops or
pcs so moving on
on this screenshot in addition to
handwriting notes using a pencil i was
also able to highlight text and attach a
digital post-it note
here here you can sort of see um you
know as well as highlighting text on
screen you can you can also underline uh
within the uh within the functionality
of my scene this is which is obviously
quite useful when you're going through
documents
on this particular one i made a note on
digital post-it note
the next page which i'll show in a
moment shows the post-it note expanded
by simply clicking on it
and then moving on
if you're referring to a lengthy
document in mycmus it's possible to use
the go to
page function and type in a page number
which will then automatically take you
to to that page in the document really
useful for say budget or or lengthy
planning policy documents for example
using using mycenas on a tablet or a pc
on a tablet you can pinch the screen to
zoom in and out so you can select
different views ranging from a
continuous view facing continuous view
facing view a single page or even a
night night mode view it's very
versatile i'll just show you
as you can see
okay
you can easily search in documents for
particular phrases in my cms in this
case i i searched for uh i searched for
fireworks and the document highlighted
each instance that disappeared
and i think that's um you know
that's that that's all i've got to say
really unless anyone's got any questions
okay
okay
better lovely thank you
okay
the exempt report will be presented by
portfolio holder for environment and
place counselor david sperin
i just asked on you that because i'd
already done they've walked out
you